yesterday early afternoon by the way
Louis joining me at the desk today it's
weird having you sitting over here Louis
but here you are it's weird to be here I
was having a conversation with my dad on
the phone we were talking about brexit I
was telling him I was looking at flights
for upcoming vacations and how it was
very interesting that now with Turkish
Airlines setting up Istanbul Airport as
a sort of gateway to all of Europe and
much of Asia
you can basically fly from Boston to
anywhere in Europe for 600 bucks in the
next few months going through Istanbul
and my dad said yeah that is true but
you know attacks can happen anywhere but
they have happened recently at Istanbul
Airport and indeed just hours after that
phone call with my dad we learned that
three attackers detonated bombs and
opened fire at the Istanbul Airport
yesterday at minimum 41 people were
killed dozens and dozens one estimate at
147 one estimate over 200 in terms of
the number wounded and the long story
short of the attack is that two gunmen
opened fire with automatic weapons at a
security checkpoint outside the airport
then detonated their explosives
meanwhile a third attacker set off
explosive in the parking lot most of the
dead are Turks although some foreigners
as I mentioned this airport increasingly
a sort of gateway to too much of the
world some foreigners also killed
flights out of Istanbul Airport
immediately cancelled last night ones on
their way were diverted this is the
third busiest airport in Europe and the
11th busiest in the world who did it
initially both the Islamic state and
Kurdish militants were being considered
as possible perpetrators a few hours
later the Turkish Prime Minister Banali
yield room in decay shion's point to the
Islamic state but why what about the
timing and the circumstances in the
specifics point to Isis ISIL - call them
what you will one hypothesis suggests
that the recent reconciliation between
Turkey and Israel might have angered
ISIL militants Israel and Turkey
announced a pretty significant deal to
restore diplomatic relations this is a
really positive step after six years of
estrangement and Mustafa Akyol a
prominent Turkish
columnist wrote yesterday on Twitter
quote the fact that the attack came
right after the Turkish Israeli deal
might not be an accident if Isis is that
fast in response the terrorists arrived
at the airport in a taxi according to
Turkish Prime Minister Yildirim who said
more details would be shared later as of
this morning Lewis still nobody has
claimed responsibility of tat of the
attack to be clear there have been other
attacks in Turkey over the last year or
two where no one ultimately claimed
responsibility but they are believed to
have been perpetrated by ISIL yeah
usually when it is a suicide bomber it
tends to be someone from these extremist
religious groups and then when it's when
it's a bomb that detonates without it
being attached to someone well more
likely in that case to be the Kurds
which are kind of battling the Turks and
it's it's a messy situation for those
saying obviously it was ISIL Turkey is
as Lewis sort of alluded to
simultaneously facing threats from both
ISIL and Kurdish militants who are
fighting a war against the Turkish state
in the southeast of Turkey and for
example back in February a car bombing
was attributed to Kurdish militants as
Lewis astutely suggesting there an
explosion not on the body of an
individual person and as a sort of big
picture reminder Turkey is a NATO ally
it really was once a safe haven of
stability in the Middle East
increasingly a hub of chaos and violence
more recently Istanbul Airport a real
hub in the area and interesting louis
that there was one of two of these
individuals
detonating their explosives at a
checkpoint outside the airport similar
to how security is done at tel aviv at
least in that element and certainly
something we talked about how you can go
right up to the security line at most
american airports without having passed
through any screening yeah it's it's a
problem it was pre security they knew
they wouldn't get through security with
their devices and they didn't plan to
it's a crazy airport I've been there
multiple times yes there are crowds
everywhere it's and and how far out do
you go you know where where how r out
does the security
how can you really prevent things like
this from happening at an airport of
that size right definitive you know and
when we talk about it's the same thing
as why passed a law when it wouldn't
prevent any but there are some people
that will not be affected or prevented
from doing X by that law when we talk
about security measures yes it is very
difficult to get everybody but if you
have these sort of concentric circles of
security you can at least in most cases
deter some people and also reduce the
damage that is done here
significant damage done regardless